(tape clicks)
- So I was looking through
our videographer's footage
when I saw this.
(screen whooshing)
(lively music)
- Because I forgot my line.
- Cut.
- (laughs) Oh, my God.
(♪ Girls Just Wanna Have Fun ♪)
(screen whooshes)
(clapper clacking)
(person laughs)
- Really?
(water splashing)
(singer singing in Spanish)
(screen beeps)
- [Chad] You know?
(beep)
- What's my line?
- That's not the line.
- That's not my line.
♪ Girls wanna ♪
♪ Wanna have fun ♪
(hands clapping)
♪ Girls ♪
(person blows raspberries)
(record scratching)
(crickets chirping)
- Sorry.
(people laughing)
- Oh, ew.
Gross.
(bell dings)
(singer sings in Spanish)
- Chad.
(singer singing in Spanish)
- [Hugo] Oh.
- I'm so sorry. That was really funny.
(Eugenio laughing)
- [Chad] On Valentine's Day?
- I know.
- (laughs) Sorry.
- Ah.
- Get her something nice like jewelry.
Because the J is
silent with you guys.
(laughs)
(Rafael laughing)
(screen beeps)
- No, it's...
- Cut.
(hand thumps)
(beeping)
(Pablo speaking in Spanish)
- Stop interrupting.
(beep)
- Sorry.
(people laughing)
(ball whooshes)
(tongue blabbering)
(clapper thuds)
(people laughing)
(lips smacking)
(door thuds)
(Isabel speaks in Spanish)
(employee speaks in Spanish)
(screen whooshes)
(upbeat music)
(remote control clicks)
- You have to be
stern with him.
(Rafael indistinctly speaking)
(people laughing)
I'm sorry.
- You got this. Whoo.
- Great blooper, by the way.
(people chattering)
(clapper clacks)
- Land on these two.
Oh, my God.
- Let me do it again.
(screen beeps)
(bags thudding)
(hand thumps)
(Jessica blows raspberries)
- Oh.
- Let's just have fun.
- Nuevo.
(singer speaking in Spanish)
- Whoa!
(Isabel squeals)
(people giggling)
(phone ringing)
(metal clanging)
(singer singing in Spanish)
- It's a wrap, guys.
- Yeah.
(people cheering)
- Boom.
(tape clicks)
Brilliant, right?
(logo booming)